... People feel a lot of guilt
There is a section of social psychology that claims to be
Most people think they are better than others
But I do not believe it. This is not what I have noticed in my life.
I may be biased, because I am a psychiatrist
I see people suffering in secret more than others in general
But I'm not sure about that
You do not have to go much deeper into people's lives
So you find something tragic
I do not mean the tragedies that are so superficial, I mean, for example
That your mother is suffering from Alzheimer's, or that your close friend has committed suicide, or
A relative of you suffers from cancer, or your child may have a disease
Or, for example, there is a bug in you
Because everyone suffers from at least one very serious sermon
If you do not suffer, you will suffer from it soon.
This sense of tragedy is always in the hearts of people
Also, in my personal experience, it is rare to meet someone who says:
"I do everything I can, I'm a wonderful person,
I do not think I can do better "
If you meet someone like that, you're going to be cocky, are not you?
And with you the right,
But most people do not think so
But feel that they can improve themselves
They are fully aware of their mistakes and do not feel that they are the best image of themselves
What happens in the story of Adam and Eve also is that
(When you open the eyes of people) and become aware, and this is what I think,
They are expelled from Paradise, and become within history
History is where there are birth pains
And your husband controls you
You have to work hard, which is not done by another animal, because you are aware of the existence of the future
You have to work and sacrifice the pleasure of the present for the future, always! You know that death is inevitable
And carry it all on your back.
For me, there is nothing more realistic than that
This is the case as I see it
Unless you are naive to the fullest, there is a part of your life
Can be linked to this picture!
And why? I mean
We are truly fantastic creatures, because we do not really belong to existence.
This is expressed in the idea of ​​falling (from Paradise)
"The people feel that they have a religion, and they have to push it into existence,
For the crime of their existence. something like that.
Perhaps because we are aware that we have to offer something of value to those around us
In order to be tolerated during our work
But it's deeper than that!
Humans live in a post-devastation world
This is expressed in Genesis. It is interesting.
Because there is the story of Adam and Eve, there are two disasters in principle
There is a catastrophe opening the eyes of Adam and Eve, to which we will speak in detail,
And become aware, and know they are naked
And open their eyes, right? Those are the words used.
Open eyes means gaining awareness
Because the eyes are linked to consciousness in humans, because we are very theoretical animals.
The expression "open-eyed"
Is the expression of getting awareness
Adam and Eve soon became conscious, naked.
The traditional interpretation of this is linked to the sin of sex.
But I do not think so. I do not think that's what it means.
Although it is related to this.
But I think it means to realize that you are a disgrace,
If you dream that you are a disgrace on a stage in front of people, this is not a sex dream!
Unless you're a pervert, right?
But you want to cover yourself, and go down quickly from that theater!
So, being naked before an audience is to receive the rule of society
And its focus on ... clear folds
This makes people conscious of themselves, and that is the case of a human being.
It's tied to neurosis in the five attributes model, but people do not like it at all!
Do not like to make their weaknesses the focus of the group.
It is one of the great concerns of the people.
One is social humiliation, the other is limited life and death
For example
The person who greets the community, is both shy at the same time.
Because she (usually a woman) believes she will suffer
A large heart attack attracts attention in a public place, making itself a laughingstock during its death
If so
This is a good example of the common fears, which represent human beings.